世界のみなさんこんにちはカール社長です
皆さん怖いものってありますが人によって怖いものってさまざま
ベビーが怖いって言う人もいればを掛けが強い人もいるある食べ物がきれいな人がいる
人限定
品物ですよね人によってこんなにも様々な強いもとなった
ですが1人には共通してはコア
うわってを方法のあるかもしれません多分なんですけどこれが強いと思いますこちら
タッピーオーバーです
いやー高はいいよこれはれ最近屋根若い人が出た票かのドリンクとかよく飲んでいると
思うんですけども
あの皆さんよく見てください
黒ないやおいしせよ待つ間力美味しいなはから僕もフェイス中スポってくるのおいしい
で愛甲たまんねぇもっと伸びてヘッドが黒いんです皆さんよくよく考えてみてください
黒いつぶってね雑魚はいいよね普通に黒い粒がね家の中でほっぽついて落ちたりしてる
だけだもんでっ
ねっに取れる分ボブしむしろそんな日本
い気持ちになるんですよわからない僕の仮説なんですけども多分黒い球体って共通して
皆さんにおそろせ恐怖心を与えるものだと思うんですよそれが増してや今だけたくさん
あると
すっげえ怖いと思うんで今日の動画ですねまぁそうなんですけど今からよく
netricoh 入ってターゲット眠りが深いんでそいつの周りにタピオカを
めっちゃ並べば
ていますそうして目が覚めて周りを見渡すと黒い渋滞って入ってそれもホニーはダメよ
買ってわかんないからさっき考えているんだもうすぐ頭をよぎってもう
んだよワンダー思考回路がショートするんじゃないように編みです寝起きで大量の旅8
日があると強い雪
やっていきましょでは行こういっぱい撮りタピオカ作っていきましょう何か作るの
めんどくさそうなんですよね打当させたお湯に約1時間がない入れてなきゃいけないと
意気な間にあたる3が深みは朝5時なんすぬ一度作るしかないんで入れてきます
あーマジで怖いうーんこれだけでももう恐怖映像やで
いいいい
[音楽]
黒い球体 java 強い強いこれでしばらくいます
ん
ああああああ
いいいい
boo
me
うはいもう多分女も d でしょう
完成しましたーー
すげーだったよくわかんないけど正月の女医がしますねそれは水で気がします
[音楽]
おすごいすごいすごいはちゃんとプリプにしてるなぁ
ずろうちょっとひと粒食べてみますいただきます
あった秒かさそりゃそうだ味の方はちゃんとおいしくなっておりますというわけで早速
準備ができました
もつ料理で私のミッションはこの大量のかぴお顔には上に出ている
後輩を起こさない表にして彼の周りに一家日竜は5階でございます果たして
大量のタピオカ&の場合はおくとどんな反応するでしょうか
ではビック秒
ギターってどうよ
def
b
ん
bb
えっ
うんうん
うん
トゥデイ
me
いいいいい
[音楽]
adj
tease
ん
うん
he to
reloop いっ
ブーフーウーを
ん
[拍手]
プー
rar
me
goo
[拍手]
tan
ん2
me
ん
パヴェませんってが大きななんかめちゃくちゃ銃で撃たれた痕みたいになってるんです
けど大きいでとまして声と思うんですよ
黒いこんなの貼っペラペラですかねつまりと思うんですよ
tan
[音楽]
ブーバーはぁあああああいい
ああああああっはぁん
はっはっは
me
タピオカだから合わせしなさいはいというわけでてる時にハードも愛がタピオカニーナ
目が一番強い雪っていう
一番怖い